thousand asks who is your favorite
comedian thousand moments let me give
you that answer but before I do Steve
cuz I love you so much show them show
them tell everybody what you just said
before went to question because you had
a good rationale for ruining the show's
audio the noise that I made during the
last episode was because I was pulling
up Paul's YouTube channel which is a
Minecraft Channel by the way so well
done cool now that I found out it's a
Minecraft Channel you may want to change
that up because that is one competitive
space all right my favorite comedian of
all time I I would probably say that it
is a tie because I want to give it's a
three-way tie between Richard prior uh
Eddie Murphy and Chris Rock and now if
you go back and watch all of my Keynotes
and watch its Cadence you may see where
the influence comes from oh crap wait
subscribe I need subscriptions because I
can't push this many right hooks in
Social so subscribe